all right tv night with my throat
[Applause]
you're going on a date with lois so
disrespectful
oh hey there little fella
[Music]
wake up buddy it is
i have an owner
he's superman and um
[Music]
like a melody my dog is the best
but he's not the greatest with other
animals this just seems gross we need
gross smelling stuff is one of the
greatest joys of being a dog next to
licking any part of your body and i lick
myself all the time well that explains
the breath
superman i am lulu and you will kneel
before me
oh aren't you a little ray of sunshine
what's going on
[Music]
you're invulnerable i should be a lot
more dead right now right all of us have
superpowers
still working out the kinks i didn't see
anything
[Music]
are you okay my best friend is in danger
and you have to help me you know what
they say about dogs don't you never feed
us chocolate we love unconditionally
[Music]
ace deploy canine shield what is a k-9
excellent shielding that seemed
incredibly painful
can't i have gotten a magic hammer or
something
what do i have here
oh squeezy bruce
that better be a licensed toy or i will
freak out
[Music]